ahead of the first match day we met
Wolfsburg's ricardo rodriguez one of the
Bundesliga's best left-backs and defense
an attack last season he scored six
goals but she's rich she's really smart
where others lose their heads he stays
calm we go I Swiss with chili and
Spanish roots he's the middle of three
brothers Roberto the oldest Francisco
the youngest now also at vols book all
three play professional football as hell
ain't Ricardo what did your parents do
differently Oh shred too doggin it's
hard to say my father loved football me
plated himself football at football eat
and hot air balloons buggies build not
and as high a level as we play today but
he was a good player idiots but what I
know food father that has certainly
contributed to what we have now those of
you at oz itself and I think there's
been a little luck as well 10k yeah
soham beating I'm happy that I'm able to
do this in lutely to this awesome on
conn ave NY three sons all become
professional footballers there must be
something special perhaps that
upbringing maybe they learned something
that other kids didn't I'm not gonna
feel it's all gonna yeah you can Navabi
were raised well we bought a new sofa
gay though we don't have a lot of money
but we were totally normal he's gone
some all we couldn't do everything we
wanted countenance nachala slicin what's
a Walton but we were happy we always had
enough to eat rotten tomatoes ways and
we were raised in a neighborhood where
it was only about football often whoa
whoa whoa really keen that in lots of
kids played football and we also played
with our father bought there's been a
long day since we were small we were
street kids I always had football on our
minds with alvin and Copeland
just doesn't kinder dolls that's partly
what do you need to make it to prove
yourself mom bro Talon Talon you tell it
you need talent for sure it's apparent
when you're good at something he threw
was then when you get older you see if
you're really good and have a necessary
desire I did and he's was there I wasn't
that good in school but I was already
thinking about what I could do after one
date that I always had problems with
schoolwork big problem why do I be on
the knee and then I had football and I
focused on that woman because as I said
you need talent desire and a bit of luck
I had all those things I'm really happy
about that davish ford focus here on dad
your younger brother he does it clean
and Buddha oh here's another stimulus
it'd be really happy that he's here and
you can play with me it means a lot to
me that he got the chance to come here
not so common I have to say though he
made it happen himself he's a good
person a good guy hey you're undecided
coming here a dozen into it so coming up
yes among you start the season now as
runners-up as German Cup champions a
super cup champions does that make
things different yeah on this decision
don't definitely be different because
the club's now look at us differently
and we're always aiming to trip us up
they'll see it's emergent invention
important bye have a nice air tube
furnace we had a really good season and
we won the Cup you hadn't it sell this
gave us all other teams will give
everything to steal point cloud cannon
on them yeah busman's will hurt here
from fun when you listen to what people
are saying in the club it all sounds
very confident a bit more confident than
last season yeah so much yeah that's
okay because we earned it you have a
nice outfit int it must be nice to say
we're not afraid talk amongst your
cloudy yeah for sure don't go all things
that should be lots of our players are
immune to fear that's good I'm one of
them I'm never afraid of anyone oh hey
she's shopping man that's good then it
has to be that way in football he's good
too so most harrowing football sign
that's right what do you want to still
achieve with both spoke
yeah I really read that open society I
want to be on top again to play at the
top giving him I want to win titles I
want to win everything you can win
important let's my giving and gone and
forth but that's how I think so Dane
cage you guys need yonder I don't know
what everyone else wants but that's what
i do i want to get better I think you
have to think that way I can think a
schmuck okay okay there's a good last
words thanks and best of luck the season
thank you soon